While quantum computers won't be suited to solve
all problems there are a few problem classes
and potential use cases where we expect
quantum computing to have an impact.
Those include simulation such
as modeling processes and systems that occur in
nature, search an optimization
involving searching for the best or
optimal solution in a situation with
many possible answers, and mathematics
and processing data with complex structure
including applications for machine learning.
Quantum algorithms take a new approach to
these sorts of problems, leveraging
the unique features of quantum physics like
superposition, interference, and entanglement.
Regular computers get stuck
exploring certain areas of the computational space
so they can not find these patterns.
Quantum computers are equipped with
extra capabilities or increased performance
for some problems afforded by their quantum nature.
To fully understand the potential of quantum computers
it requires a deep dive into computational complexity theory,
a branch of computer science that centers on
measuring and comparing the computational effort that
goes into solving different kinds of problems.
This provides a useful framework
for describing various speed-ups
and problem classes that are encountered in
computing.